Rome,
Greece.
because people are stupid.
All democracies fail
But if you crush the masses
who build your monuments,
now the people will tear it apart themselves.
Then you could just
be the one saving it
You just can't imagine the little.
like Caesar,
like sees no.
hell.
To watch their balls crushed me.
Your team what's your code name again?
The boys
Who came up with that?
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my video for the boys season four trailer
It looks absolutely crazy in the best possible way.
Like how they're going to top themselves each season.
It just gets crazier and crazier and crazier This time,
Homelander seems like he's revealed his grand plan.
And it is to go full God Emperor.
Homeland or eventually over the entire world, I think.
But really,
they're just talking about the United States
during the events of the trailer
because of the election.
but it kind of seems like his whole idea
is to basically go Caesar on Rome, basically
go from a democracy, turning it into an empire with him
being the new emperor.
there's a bunch of comic book Easter eggs for that.
So we'll get into that during the video.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
of course I'll do videos
for all of the episodes, just like I did
four previous seasons in, just like I did for Gen B.
they didn't have any new footage
for Gen V season two, even though they've renewed it
just because they literally just renewed it.
So they haven't even started filming it yet.
I literally just did a video for the Boys
Mexico series, which
they just announced, which is going to be happening
in the next couple of years, too.
But they haven't revealed much about the plot of that
and how it connects with the boys.
Season four in the Boys Season five,
but it probably year after the boys, season five,
this trailer only says that Season four
is going to premiere sometime in 2024.
My assumption is it'll be summer
or before that, hopefully March,
but I don't think it'll be quite that early.
just starting at the beginning of the trailer footage,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talked about Easter eggs
and the many, many WTF moments.
the beginning of the trailer starts with Homelander
in his apartment in Vought Tower just staring silently.
He does that a lot like his mind just goes
absolutely blank.
You wonder what is he cooking?
What is he cooking inside there?
then we get the voiceover from this new character
who we find out is talking to him later in this room
about the whole idea of going full Caesar on Rome,
basically
homelander versus the idea of democracy
in the United States even though they portrayed him
in a number of different ways during the series,
like they make him seem like he's super dumb.
He does have a certain level of intelligence,
like he starts to see the grand picture
when this person is telling him
about how he could take over the United States.
Basically.
in essentially
they make it seem like he wants to lean into the curve,
like basically get both sides of this equation,
like the far right in the far left, like the people
that are basically warring
with each of these two political parties
get them to start burning America
down, basically burning democracy down,
because we had this whole election
that's been going on in the background
with Victoria Newman in Robert Singer's character
and he plans to be the person to swoop in and fix
all the problems or claim that he's going to fix
all the problems and make everyone love him even more.
Like take all the credit for fixing
this giant civil war that America is about to start in.
Essentially, if he plans to become the new God emperor
of the United States and maybe the world, eventually,
You have to remember.
Because of his compound
V powers, he's functionally immortal.
He won't age, so he'll be emperor forever.
then, when he starts getting this idea in his head
about Rome becoming this new version of Caesar
over the United States,
they transition to butcher inside this old video store
looking like it's the aftermath of them
winning the election.
Victoria Newman and Robert Singer winning the election
basically Homelander side.
there's also a poster for polarity
that's a reference to the Gen V show.
This is meant to take place like days
after the ending of the Gen B show.
remember Victoria Neuman had that compound V weapon
in her hands and she's got it on the DL.
So it sounds like she's going to use it
or if she wants to use it at some point,
maybe as a deterrent
merrily theory during the Gen V episodes
when they were sort of getting into the weeds on that,
is that it wouldn't work on Homelander like she might
try to use it on Homelander it might just not work.
it'll either turn into some twist like that
or there'll be a left turn
because theoretically,
it would kill all superheroes, all over the planet.
And I don't think they want that to happen.
somehow things will not go the way
that Victoria Neuman is planning them to go.
I don't know if any of the Gen V
characters will show up during season four
because none of them do appear during the trailer.
Then we see Victoria Newman and Robert Singer
at what looks like a victory rally.
They're all celebrating their victory in the election.
not sure what's happening here,
but Starlight holds her hand up.
This might just be a crowd that she's addressing
like a bunch of her supporters that she's addressing.
there was the a rally of Homelander supporters
near Vought Tower.
love the look on his face here.
Like you just wonder what he's pissed off about.
It could literally be anything.
He gets pissed off so frequently.
The funny thing about the way they cut the trailer
to where the woman's talking about not killing
all these regular people Because if homelander killed
all these people who would build monuments to him
and who would lick his taint, so to speak,
it shows you the deep with the octopus,
because it's this whole weird relationship
that the Deep has with Homelander
like he's kind of terrified of him,
but he's also kind of obsessed with him.
Homelander also literally forced him to eat his friend
the Octopus.
Now he's staring at another one then we see butcher
in mother's milk and what is called truth con here.
It just seems like another one of those
crazy conventions that they visit during the series.
They did that during season three.
zoom an enhanced next to mother's milk here.
There's a bunch of conspiracy theories about what
happened to Soulja Boy being held captive by the CIA.
That's actually kind of true.
That's the funny part,
is that there's an element of truth in there.
not totally sure what's going on with Frenchie
and Kimiko in this coffee warehouse there.
Just something really shady that they're investigating.
when she talks about the different sides
of this equation, like the Starlight
supporters, the homeowner supporters
basically tearing each other apart.
They actually do start to fight with each other.
Notice that starlight is at the protests
in this kind of horrified
by what's happening here with the fight breaking out.
And you see Homelander in the background
just kind of smiling, enjoying it all, like, yes,
I am happy that this is happening
because he plans on swooping in, fixing it later
and being the grand savior,
quote unquote, to everyone that, a lot of you wondered
if they would bring black noir back
because during this next scene
we actually see him with him later
with Ryan at what seems like some sort of rally
in a couple of the new superhero
characters are introducing during season four.
This one is called Firecracker.
Notice she has bullets all over her supposedly
one of her superpowers
is just incredibly good hearing
like way beyond that of a normal superhero. But.
Just to address the elephant in the room.
The dead superhero in the room.
Why is black noir back?
Well,
there's actually a twisted explains that in the comics.
In the comics, you can actually use compound B
to resurrect dead superheroes.
the only thing, though, is that when you do that,
they just come back as, like, mindless, zombified
kind of hulks.
Like they can take basic commands,
but essentially they lose their higher brain functions.
so maybe that's what's going on with Black Noir
during season four, whatever is going on here,
it looks like this new firecracker superhero
character has a TV show called The Truth Bomb,
which is probably an ironic statement, like,
she probably just lies for Vought
because most of the programs here are all sponsored
by Vought on both networks.
It's just them peddling their wares,
getting you to buy their stuff, just saying whatever
they want you to believe.
Basically, then we finally see Jeffrey
Dean Morgan's character meeting with Butcher, who's
some sort of former coworker or former
ally of his During the series, he's going to be called
Joe Kessler, but there's not much
we know about where he actually comes from, like
if he's part of the CIA
or if he's connected to Mallory somehow.
And that's how he knew Butcher in the past.
it is kind of seems like they are old mates.
and I love the way
that he makes fun of butcher in the boys team
like who came up with that name that sounds stupid
this little girl character is actually Victoria
Neuman's daughter who's attacking Kimiko.
I'm not exactly sure what's happening in this scene,
but this just shows you what her compound V
Powers wound up turning into because remember,
Victoria Neuman dosed her with Compound V last season.
does it not look like the freakiest power
to get ever, giving someone.
Compound B powers is a bit of a dice roll.
Like they could either get really cool powers, really
low level like nothing powers or really gross powers.
in it.
This isn't a flashback.
It seems like Queen May comes back at some point.
She's wearing a different type of costume,
but it seems like she's doing some kind of song
and dance number here, like she's doing some show
we get another scene with Black Noir
with the Seven inside Vought Tower
some kind of crazy duplication power
that the superhero has.
Seems like he might be a supporter.
He's wearing a Starlight T-shirt,
but I can't read the rest of the shirt.
So either loves or he hates Starlight.
I don't know if Mother's milk is reacting to his power
or this is like a completely different scene.
But I love the way that he reacts to this.
This is his general reaction
to a lot of the crazy stuff that happens on the show.
Then they tease this weird kind of brain worm
that they're giving people.
Like there's a bunch of the jars
that they're looking at here.
It's the thing that's wiggling around inside
Butcher's temple here.
It might be some kind of mind control device
that they're trying to use
we get another funny scene of Ashley
dominating Cameron Cole here.
Like they're weird, freaky
kink scenes like we had in previous seasons.
this is basically how Ashley has been able
to blow steam off after getting abused by Homelander
and the rest of everybody inside
Vought Tower for so long.
love the way that Homelander growls here
like an animal, then takes off.
Not sure what's going on in the scene.
I just love seeing him just go crazy like this.
Then we see Ryan push someone
and just squish him against the side of the building
because he pushes them so hard.
Notice that almost everybody on
the street has their phones out in our videotaping it.
Do this, this little girl standing next to him.
So maybe Ryan thinks that he's protecting
this little girl by pushing this other dude away,
but he pushes him so hard
that he just splats against the side of the building.
that's a very homelander thing for him to do,
like just push someone away.
But you push them so hard
that their body basically explodes.
there's a bunch of stuff going on during the season.
Obviously
I've talked about in a couple of previous videos,
all those running plotlines
that they have from the end of season three.
Jensen Ackles, Soldier Boy, still alive,
still in the deep freeze, so to speak.
He's still in cryo during the Jen V show
Victoria Neuman reference Homelander
going on trial
for killing that dude at the end of season three.
They might address that briefly
at the beginning of the season,
but I'm not expecting it to be like a super huge thing
because there's no way that Homelander
would allow himself to actually go to jail
if he thought that they were a threat.
But let me know in the comments
what you're most hyped up about
if there's any questions you have based
on the trailer footage or anything that I didn't
address from the trailer,
just write it below in the comments to
And because this weekend is CC ZP Brazil Comic-Con
there are a bunch of trailers
that dropped out trying to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
I just did The House of the Dragon Season 2 Trailer.
Click here to watch that and click here
to learn about x 23 coming back during Deadpool 3
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!